Oh, Garcelle.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
Hi, Drew.
It's so wonderful
to be with you.
And you have my man here, Ross Mathews.
Rossie!
Oh, I love him so much.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I sent him a text.
I said, "Oh, my God, you look so good. You look so happy."
He said, "Stop flirting with me. I'm engaged."
(Garcelle and audience laughing)
I know.
He and I pretend like there's a possibility there.
And we know clearly there's not,
and that's weirdly why it's gonna work-
Yeah. (laughs)
For the long term.
(audience laughs)
Exactly.
And you get so into really great, deep stuff in your book,
"Love Me as I Am," which how is that title say,
like brilliant title.
Oh, thank you.
I mean, I wanted something that said, this is who I am.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, take me as I am, basically.
And "Love Me as I Am" felt a little nicer.
I mean, you talk about your family,
your father, your mother.
Will you talk to me about their relationship?
'Cause I was freaking out about the dynamic that they had.
Yeah, what was interesting
is my dad left when I was three.
So I really only knew my mom
and only knew her story as much as she told me.
And there wasn't much told because back then in Haiti,
kids were seen and not heard, right?
And so I saw her be this strong, independent woman
and that's what I knew.
And it was interesting when my dad came back into our lives,
I was 14, and I saw that she kinda gave up her power
because he became the man of the house.
(Drew sighs)
And culturally, that's also a thing in the islands,
the men sort of rule the roost.
So it was interesting to see her change in that way.
She was still strong, but in a different way.
And your grandfather and his wife,
is there a pattern here in your family?
For sure, there's a pattern.
Talk to us about that.
And I talked
about the pattern, also.
My grandfather was obviously a very strong...
He had a strong presence.
I remember when I would go and visit them,
like just who he was was bigger than life for me, right?
And then he left my grandmother and got a younger woman
and created a whole new family with her.
And it was just interesting that there were patterns.
And my dad also left my mom.
And then I chose men that were similar to my dad,
in some instinct, and I think we do that.
And I know one of my patterns
is like my dad left when I was three,
I got divorced when my son, Oliver, was three,
and then I got divorced when my two boys were three.
And I have three boys.
And I'm like, what is that?
What is that?
I feel like there's something to that.
I don't know what it is.
Now that you're looking at this pattern,
you're seeing your life, your family's,
writing this gorgeous book, "Love Me as I Am,"
where are you at now?
(sighs) Waiting for my soulmate, honestly.
I think where I am now is I feel like I'm really,
I feel like 50s is fearless, right?
Yeah.
I feel like I'm in my skin.
I know who I am. I know what I want.
And it's just waiting for the right time
to meet the right person.
I don't like apps.
I know some people do,
and that's fine.
They're hard.
I just, for me, I find it a little tough to be swiping.
I'd rather be doing that with clothes-
Yeah.
On a rack.
(all laughing)
I'd rather be swiping.
I know!
I agree.
Now I wanna talk about "The Real Housewives,"
Garcelle, for a minute.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah,
of course.
I'm dying!
Everyone is freaking out.
(Garcelle laughs)
(audience applauds)
What is going on?
Everyone's abuzz on the internet, freaking out
about the book in the...
Erika put it in the trash. What?
This is classic "Housewives." Everybody's in for it.
That's why they're da la la la la la.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
It's a juggernaut of a show.
I can't believe how many people are invested
into everything we do.
I mean, it is a cult.
I mean, it is crazy, Drew.
With 8,000 spin-offs.
This is like it's taken
over the world.
Not 8,000 spin-offs.
(Garcelle laughs)
You know what?
I posted a clip that was in the trailer of our new season.
And I guess Erika felt a certain way about it,
and-
Clearly.
Clearly. And I wish her well.
Ooh, yes.
Uh-oh.
(audience chuckling)
The look says it all.
(Garcelle chuckles)
That's high road with a I see you.
(Garcelle laughs)
Drew, you should be a housewife.
Come. Come on, Drew. (laughs)
Ironically,
I used to love drama.
(audience applauds)
And now, I'm as far away from it as possible.
But when we come back, we have some people right here
in our studio audience who actually are looking
for a few dating pointers, tips, Garcelle.
Ooh, we got them.
We got them, Drew.
A little love bug.
Okay.
(audience cheers)
We got them.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat pop music)